[Music]
what's going on guys the defenders it's
hitting Netflix and there are four
different shows making up five seasons
of television that led up to this
momentous occasion so we're going to
break it down for you and make sure that
you know everything you need to know and
can dive right into the defenders and
we're telling you which episodes are
must watch also there will be spoilers
and we've got a pretty cool panel of
experts to talk about it with first she
is one of the co-hosts of Marvel movie
news welcome back to the show marki
McCarty yeah thanks for having me and
this young man is a friend of the show
he's also a co-host of Marvel movie news
welcome back boys Andre then I started
here with Deadpool
yeah my first injury show let's start
with daredevil it was the first of these
Netflix shows and it got the ball
rolling
walk me through who are the just the key
players that I need to know from they're
devil so the first season that burdock
obviously both as daredevil end of Matt
Murdock this is a guy that can see well
blind and has superhuman abilities while
not being able to technically see it's
also a struggling lawyer and you have to
go know the intricacies of that it's
interesting they made a lawyer show out
of the superhero show and it worked
yeah because you saw them just like
putting the nameplate on their office
yeah that's more ruggle enough going to
happy hour at the bar and that leaves in
the foggy who's his best friend their
attorneys together they have this firm
together a lot of times funny knows who
variable is and they have this
relationship where he doesn't like what
you're doing to your sexist friends so
there's this great conflict there you're
a lawyer you're supposed to be helping
people yeah in a mask due to what they
call that a vigilante someone who acts
outside of the law I really love Karen
page she's really important how much
Claire Temple is set up in terrible is
the next fury of marble nap she
assembles she gathers this time she's in
every show
she's vital and she's a night nurse in
daredevil season one she catches him
back together and you realize that like
she handles that crazy level of
superhuman well in in daredevil the
supporting cast shape to Matt Murdock is
and his mentor and trainer from his
youth stick is a blind
curmudgeon a crotchety old man that you
don't like not to like
but since it's got none you do Scott
Glenn amazing Vincent
Oh free Oh as king pegs inspired yet the
portrayal of Wilson Fisk is arguably as
important immaterial daredevil I mean
Wilson Fisk I wished that some of the
Marvel movies had a villain of that
caliber I love Madame Gao and they're
known because she is a complete badass
yeah beautiful little woman oh look at
her oh she's a mom three episodes I
think are really important I think
watching the second episode for the
hallway sight I think yeah really yes
look very low people are saying when
they say hallway fight like there's a
reason the defenders trailer opens the
hallway like everybody knows like that's
going to be a thing and it's more of
them having their own Hall fix I also
think episode 7 that really like has a
lot of stick back story clearly he's
important you really need to understand
the mystical elements go into defenders
and then episode 13 is it's a finale and
it feels like a finale it's a wrap up of
season one you get a closure how much
characters it's the first time terrible
silly suits up so at the end of season
one daredevil has taken out with some
fists with law and his fists which is
great we've built the universe to a
point but it's very much open after
season one daredevil the next series we
were introduced to Jessica Jones walk us
through uh some Jessica Jones marquee
she has superhuman powers she has super
strength she's basically involve
ompletely invulnerable I mean we start
off and we know that she is a private
detective we know that she has a heck of
a drinking problem whiskey is this
woman's middle name and but along with
that she's also a fantastic detective
that's just carrying around this huge
load on her bag so she's a may employ of
carrie-anne moss and you know her as
Trinity from metric yo oh she's a
hard-boiled lawyer the major villain
that then Jessica Jones kilgrave the
purple man this is played by David
Tennant through the use of mind-control
in pheromones he's able to have people
do whatever it is that he wants you to
do it's like the hypnotist from hell and
he believes that he is in love with
Jessica Jones for supporting cast is
extremely great we have Mike Colter my
closer is Luke Cage yep that was our
first introduction to
bulletproof himself absolutely he owns a
bar and of course Jessica Jones is going
to wind up in that bar and they
immediately hit it off and buy hit it
off of me and then our grade yeah with
Jessica we also have a Rachel Taylor and
she plays Trish Walker you would know
her from the comics as a Hellcat mm-hmm
but in here she's she's a radio tacos
and actually one of the major things
which is like a gentleman is that she
has to prove that killgrave exist Trish
Walker goes on her radio show and calls
kilgrave out and of course he responds
yes brings us all around to this whole
thing of IgH basically when jessica
jones was a child she got into a
horrific accident and then this
mysterious organization picked up all
the bills afterwards and then all said
she had powers the accident that killed
her parents yeah yes there is this one
episode of episode 8 I've called aka
WWJD in it you see where killgrave has
bought Jessica Jones childhood home
welcome home Jessica Jones this is a
particularly great episode because you
find out about what makes chill Grave
tick I didn't have a loving parents our
family great what's another episode that
we should take a look at to give us a
full jessica jones refresher the finale
is chillingly beautiful yeah I kill
grave has come to the point where fine
Jessica doesn't want him she should want
him but he enlists like this crowd of
people to serve as a human barrier
between him and Jessica Jones while he's
also calling forth to her and then he
has them fight each other yeah the
killer got it so creepy to see everybody
just under his spell yeah it's chilling
by that point she's immune to his powers
and she snaps that neck are there any
other points that we should be familiar
with around the end of the season we do
have an injured Luke Cage
so that also brings in Claire temple
yeah once again we have a Trish Walker
throughout this series
she's gone from being a little bit naive
about the world into someone that you
can easily see strapping on hellcat and
taking that around the town so we have
an i GH this mysterious corporation that
we know has these pills that not only do
healing abilities but we'll get the
people addicted to the pills where they
then basically have to work for that
organization to continue to live and
Jessica Jones said she proved that
killgrave that exists she's actually
released by the police and to back into
her her own messy life great thank you
for that comprehensive snapshot of
Jessica Jones
so after Jessica Jones season one back
to daredevil season two what are some of
the main things we need to know about
season two of daredevil Punisher yes
daredevil season two did what a lot of
movies and a lot of shows try to do it
had a lot of comic characters in it this
is a show that introduced Elektra
introduced Punisher brought back kingpin
which actually surprised me it's a show
that builds it was a secret
we know daredevil we don't need another
in foregin so this allowed for us to
build into bigger courtroom cases
there's a courtroom scene with the
Punisher on trial we can have this
insane Prison Break with the Punisher
doing everything the punch man that
sequence was out of convincing and
Punisher fight was like oh yeah we see
your hallway let's raise it violence and
the entire time it's Matt Murdock trying
to decide what's the lesser of two evils
and if there's anything that says
daredevil is what's the lesser too evil
that's all season two is you're trying
to figure out who you're rooting for so
it built on what the first season did
incredibly well by adding more
characters you loved adding more
mystical elements tell us a little more
about the hand crime syndicate so the
hand is a team of mystical ninjas they
have superhuman abilities and they also
can't technically be killed at one point
there is an entire clan of ninja scaling
a hospital you've earned that moment
with 20 hours of brilliant television
and the relationship and Elektra and
daredevil is one of the most important
and comic terrible has a lot of very
important women in his life they do a
great job with this show giving them
enough time to breathe we know Elektra
is important in this world we know at
the end of the show she's been brought
back to life and is now Elektra she is
now a fully formed undead ninja assassin
and we at the end of the show
get Punisher fully form are there any
other characters villains or otherwise
that we should know about from season
two more escalation with the hand more
powers being portrayed there's an entire
scene where there's a whole like a
literal hole in the middle of the city
that goes on for long enough they don't
know when it in yeah that's an
interesting like open Easter egg of
what's that going to be stick is
reintroduced electors the villain at
this point Punishers a quasi villain at
this point kingpins might be involved
like there's a lot of cards at play as a
second season and I really think blue is
coming tell us a couple episodes from
daredevil season two that are must watch
so if you don't have time for all of it
which I recommend make time episode 9 is
the Prison Break episode 9 is we've
already established the relationship
between Punisher and Kington and it's
fascinating because the last man that's
going to work for the Punisher in comics
or the show is kingdom that's not a
relationship but he twists them any
manipulation which shows not only that
Punisher is willing to do anything but
also that kingpin is still the kingpin
while he's behind bars yeah it shows
mastering yep they're both a power and
it's a beautiful power plays great
writing and all the while they're
doubled outside dealing with everything
else trying to stay alive it also is up
there with the hallway fight scene as
one of the craziest fights and it ends
with a bloody smear in this chest that
looks like the punisher skull so it
satisfies viewers it satisfies comic
fans it's great for the story and then
if you can only watch two episodes
episode 13 because it does a beautiful
job just like it's a summation it's
everything like this we see how powerful
the hand has become we see what madame
guy was up to we see a lecture brought
back to life we see punisher suit up we
see daredevil be at odds with his
relationship with lecturer with his
relationship with karen with foggy
he's on a roof dealing with like every
turmoil that you can possibly deal with
and he's fighting alongside his quasi
enemy slash ex-lover that's a lot to
deal with mark kiya
Luke Cage talk to us about it you know
mike colter Luke Cage you've seen him
from Jessica gem she was wrongly accused
what
sigue prison was experimented on by one
of them one of the prison guards there
and then ended up having bulletproof and
vulnerable skin and he escaped from Sea
Gate he is an ex-con he's trying to you
know live under the radar in Harlem
it starts off and pops barbershop Luke
Cage is just a guy just trying to sweep
the floors trying to sweep the floors
they're trying to do the dishes at
Harlem's paradise that introduces us to
a pretty epic villain
it's cottonmouth Stokes this character
has so many layers to it I mean
everybody wants to be the king you know
he has a huge portrait of Biggie Smalls
like in his office and it's everything
is stylized with him yeah but he's he's
a killer along with that you have Mariah
Dillard best played by alfre woodard
politics is where the power is Cornell
she's a Councilwoman Mariah and Stokes
are kind of in league with each other
pop the character pop ends up being
killed by toun who ends up being killed
by Stokes because nobody kills pops pops
is uh he's a figure maker of yeah
exactly
Luke Cage and cottonmouth have this so
antagonistic where Luke ation knows that
he's he's down and dirty he's horrible
he wants to take him down but the
community doesn't necessarily know that
a really great supporting cast that we
get for instance we get a misty night a
detective she actually is undercover and
you first meet her in Harley's paradise
with luke cage's
taking over for a bartender and there
are immediate sparks between the two of
them they went out for coffee last night
went out for coffee so then you know
what that means another key player in
Luke Cage is shades Alvarez he is a
manager of an unknown villain at that
time and he's working with cottonmouth
and at times threatening cottonmouth to
get the job done get this Luke Cage
character out of the way right who is
this unknown unknown if it's diamondback
who also is it turns out to be luke
cage's brother so what are some episode
you should get max Cage but if you could
only get minimum cage minimum Kade yeah
okay well yes
definitely see episode 7 it's called
manifest in this you explored the
childhood of Mariah Dillard and also of
cottonmouth and you find out all about
mama Mable who was this big mob boss you
really understand why it is that they
are the way there are you actually feel
for them as you get to that point and
manifest Mariah kills cottonmouth and
Shay's Alvarez sees it and cleans it up
look what Luke Cage did you cut it so
and then of course episode 13 the finale
at the end of Luke Cage cottonmouth is
dead
Mariah Dillard is in a very impressive
position of power she has shades Alvarez
in her corner also so you're like oh
that's a very powerful duo that can
continue on in the future misty night is
so part of a you know NYPD but she is
also a Luke Cage aside now Luke Cage
unfortunately is being taken back to
prison you're under arrest for your
lawful escape from seagate prison him
and Claire temple have a relationship oh
yes also Diamondback he is in the
hospital because he has been defeated
however of Noah Bernstein who was the
same doctor that was trying to help Luke
Cage earlier in the series he it looks
like he's going to be helping out
diamondback so that is a possibility
that Diamondback might have the same
powers that Luke Cage does and then you
also have to wonder is this part of this
mysterious organization that we visited
in jessica jones IgH gotcha Wow a lot of
food for thought there Marcia thank you
for breaking that down now there's one
season of television left the first
season of iron fist just give me a
thumbnail of who iron fist is and what
his powers are Danny ran focuses his Chi
into an actual and actionable force and
that is manifested in a glowing fit but
he's also a billionaire he went away
into Kunlun for 15 years gotcha
his plane crashed he didn't choose this
life it happened at him as he lost his
family his billionaire family he's
trapped in this world he comes back and
that fish-out-of-water story like he's
been training in this mystical land of
martial arts and came back and I owe it
this is my company it's been run without
me what's going on how do I acclimate
I'm not wearing shoes so the things the
show does right it moves the story along
with carry and mosses character it was
the story along with our universe
building it moves the story along with
the supporting characters the supporting
characters and Isis are amazing who do
you think is going to be recurring in
defenders call him in better crawling
wing ok calling wings owns her own dojo
and she also teaches he teaches kids so
she's she's down on the streets with
these kids she doesn't believe in things
like fighting for money but yet she does
fight for money and it kicks some
spectacular ass while doing it to then
provide money for those kids also in
putting a love interest of Iron Fist
well well the Clare assemble grows more
that Templars been all the shows she has
a really meaty role in this she's an a
lot more episodes than anyone expected
she has a growth as a character where
she's she's taking care of all these
superheroes she's not a superhero it's
starting to wear on her and you see her
be like guys I'm a person like it out
for my mom Arnold but let me be clear
temple so that was interesting I love
that she took up actual claws to fight
like at one point you see that she's
ready to fight if she has to and that's
really powerful and the supporting
characters the Meacham's is the family
the propia Destro's family i don't know
how important they're going to be going
on in the defenders because that
storyline was the focus and I feel like
audiences kind of voted with no don't do
that anymore
okay so the three episodes I recommend
for that flavor please episode 6
immortal emerges from cave well it was
directed by RZA yeah look at my top one
Lewton eagle on penis so kungfu in that
episode you get size who's one of the
first villains to fight iron fist you
have a bride and i'm spider perfect it
feels like a comic book it feels like it
also feels like a video game
your fighting bosses your titling up
plus you get Madame Gao mask out the one
that set up this tournament that iron
fist so she was gonna be like Zeus
terrible she's been involved in behind
the scenes so it's really good episode
to just catch you up with this character
because you don't have the semantics you
don't have the all the core finestra
knowledge you have a man fighting that
is an iron fist
oh so that's the episode episode 8
introduces Liu
pan of the drunken master yet last ten
minutes of episode eight watching yeah
well Louis Tam was an actor who was very
close to plein air insist himself he's
very charming charismatic and it shows
what martial arts like the 70s
representation of martial arts could
have been on this show and I think the
episode that will play in the defenders
mystical element the most so I've said
six and eight so far I also think
episode 12 it wraps up Davos on Davos is
a supporting character who wanted to be
Iron Fist who thought he deserved the
Iron Fist he has this entitled sense of
Kunlun which is the mystical world they
didn't really show he was actually
supposed to stay there and guard it
Davos actually leaves to go get him
since like hey you're Iron Fist I want
it to be Iron Fist I should be on this
but I'm not on as you are dude get back
to your post
gotcha final episode of Iron Fist where
do we leave off something that we just
didn't mention but you could you would
find out during the series is that there
is a character Harold who is killed and
then is resurrected that has to do it
all and is that in like the same way
that a lecturer was resurrected yes and
people sing periodically and yes yes we
know that a Madame Gao and Davos in
league with each other okay so that's it
I could see his butt hurt that he's not
the artist man Madame Gao is very
powerful in fact we don't really know
water so Madame Gao is there still a
giant hole there still a giant here
right yeah we have Ward and Danny they
are running the company ran enterprises
together yeah I'm going to go back to
come on Danny and Colleen arrived to
discover that not only has it
disappeared and it's gone but there are
a bunch of dead hand the hand like in
the past pathway that would have led to
came alone so you don't know what so
something stronger than the villain
we've been setting up for four seasons
five seasons four shows is taken out
these these mysterious ninjas and
they're in this mystical land of Kremlin
and it's the beautiful thing between
like daughters of dragons set up and
iron fist becoming more fully formed
cool okay so now we're ready for the
defenders um what do we know about the
storyline what we're going to about to
get into with the defenders it's going
to unite all four of these shows into
one very interesting flavor yeah
My name is Matthew Murdock I'm returning
I'm named mortal iron just you what
you're on the same side we know that
they're going to be leaning into the
action know something that we also know
is that Sigourney Weaver is a baddie in
it yeah not only that we already know
from the trailers and everything like
that that there is going to be epic
hallway scene most likely in that
building right after they've left a
meeting with supporti we'd probably look
like fast six and it's like a hallway
that's impossible along like that
airplanes seemed at last 12 minutes I
like that you guys have caught me up and
gotten me super stoked on the defenders
are you excited about the defenders
what's your favorite season of these
other four shows let us know in the
comment section below we want to know I
want to thank my awesome guest mark Kia
McCarty Coy's Andrew thank you for
breaking it down and educating us today
and thank you for watching I'm Howard me
up on Twitter bye bye
[Music]